this is a production of cornell
university
no problem uh thanks everybody this is
episode 10 of the cornell turks show
this year we're halfway through our
kind of spring series here um this
friday we're talking sports tour for our
guest today
a phd candidate from penn state uh evan
my skitty we've got some really cool
stuff we're going to talk to evan about
um regarding surface playability of
infields and
and some cool data visualization that
we'll talk about a recent sports
management article that evan wrote
that got us interested in this but uh as
always we'll start with frank a little
overview of the week
uh maybe some uh fun little tidbits in
there from the last week
ah for sure for sure evan i believe this
is your handiwork brother back
back in the day yeah it's a good i like
that pattern that's usually what we put
in for opening day the uh the diamonds
and pirate pirates took one on the chin
yesterday but uh the field looks as good
as it always does so matt's doing a
great job there
that's so great well don't talk to me
about taking it on the chin
we paid 200 million dollars we're four
games five games in
and i think the yanks have scored five
runs and
half of them are on two home runs uh
that they have
evidence as you can tell we're talking
baseball but if you think you're having
a hard time with your soccer field
how about trying to line out that baby
uh
week and trying to keep that in shape
and so uh let me just review
things for the week and remind you we
didn't see the sports guys last week we
did
lawn and grounds last week um just you
know no i don't need to remind you all
you gotta do is look out your door
and they're out playing spring sports
are playing
youth sports are playing everybody's
feeling like it's uh pretty wide open
now
a lot of comfortableness around high
school sports maybe not as many fans
but certainly as you can see on the left
and i showed last week
our division one soccer team is at it on
our rye poa
soccer field and it's really uh sort of
taking it on the chin here so
um since we're talking about traffic and
use and wear
like to be uh out ahead and current on
these things
uh prostrate not weed problem is
actively germinating now that's a
picture on the bottom left of the
seedlings you gotta look really close it
might look like a grass
but you can easily see the dicots uh the
very seedling they tend to come up in a
big bunch
and then literally thin quite a bit over
time to the point where they become like
a toupee or as
randy prostak says sometimes a doily uh
they tend to be
uh crowded along uh high traffic areas
on your sports field but also along the
curbsides
where it's a little bit warmer soil most
of these germinates are happening
uh on along the sidewalk where it's
quite a bit warmer
or as you get further south obviously in
the compacted areas that also might get
and stay warmer quicker now a good
identifying feature as these things get
older is this little piece of membrane
that happens at the nodes i'm teaching
wheat id and turf now so i
i thought i'd bring this to everybody's
attention this is a good way to identify
this plant once you get it
in the landscape to know what you've got
it's a summer annual it's really up
quick
it's going to flower soon and get out of
there and this is a clear indication of
poor soil problems so if you're fighting
or seeing uh problems with this weed uh
even in your baseball infields it's
likely from the compaction that you're
doing there
now since we're talking about weeds you
go to our forecast website
for those of you able to use chemical
herbicides in the spring
it is not the ideal time as you know now
of course dan scheid told us last week
on the grounds edition
uh he uses herbicides here at cornell
and they spray him at fall break
uh so when we have broadleaf issues we
target some areas
and we do it when the students are
primarily not traipsing around the
campus
so if you're doing it now obviously you
may have some exposure issues you want
to be careful about that you obviously
got to follow all the rules and ranks
but you see here the two formulations
particularly of 24d that you could have
in your compound
is going to determine how effective they
are in the spring
based on some research that was done
back at purdue many years ago
back designing growing degree day models
for spring dandelion control using
24d and so you can see you know there's
a slight
advancement to ester the ester
formulation
uh works a little bit better uh you know
in under cooler temperatures
you need warmer temperatures for the
amine uh to be effective
so we're still quite a ways from doing
any kind of control here
i'll draw your attention to the latest
uh growing degree day tracker
where we're looking at crabgrass uh
pre-emergence timing
and again this model is suggesting that
we're late
now i can tell you people are regularly
commenting to me and in our conference
call weekly
uh we hear about the forsythias maybe
being a better
uh target for this now so we're seeing a
lot of forsythia bloom
we still think we have a week or so or
two for germination and again if it
starts to get cool
we could start to arrest this entire
process so again
if you're using pre-emergent herbicides
you want to think about this but the
other thing to do in sports fields
operations
is to get some seed down as you start to
see the turf
thinning from the traffic it's best to
start getting some overseeding down well
of course
overseeding and unirrigated areas are
going to be related to
you know the amount of rainfall you get
so you know we haven't had that much
rainfall through much of the region you
know less than an inch
except along the coast or wherever rich
buckley is
wherever rich buckley is it seems to
rain on a pretty regular basis and
usually
on thursdays and you can see uh over the
last week
the little bit of rain we've gotten is
it been in central south new jersey and
look
along the coast uh at the east end of
long island as well
but overall in the last 30 days
much of new york state is 25 to 75
of normal so we're certainly not at
normal rainfall so we're going to be
a little bit on the dry side there's
some reprieve coming for sure
uh in the next couple of days but no one
thinks it's going to be
a big soaking rainfall maybe an inch if
we're lucky but it might just be
a quarter or a half in some places now
soils are warming right soils are
getting going right
and so now out when you're down in the
metropolitan new york area
uh you can start to see and that you're
starting to get warm soils into the 50s
and you're probably going to start to
see some growth now with
average temperatures still you know well
above normal 10 degrees above normal
into the 60s
we're at a really high potential for
growth so
you're going to see your sports field
grasses start to grow
significant i wanted to draw your
attention to some work that another good
wisconsinite has done and doug uh was
talking to us about bill kreiser who was
on the show
a couple of weeks ago we were talking
about non-uh you know growth potential
and growth and traffic and pgrs
and bill's done a lot of clipping
collection over the years
and what he did is he tracked uh
non-irrigated kentucky bluegrass growth
in nebraska
from may to october there is a predicted
growth potential and then there is the
actual clipping production that he
measured during the year
and you see there is a disconnect
particularly when you're not
irrigated now here is irrigated tall
fescue
and again early in the season lots of
high predictions for growth
uh but then during the season you start
to see
july august where the actual end to
predict it is close
and then in the shoulders of the season
not so much so again this is weird if
you're thinking about bimodal curves
of cool season turf grasses you would
think it would be
a typical bimodal curve and this is the
argument bill was making
would be really good growth in the
spring low in the summer
and then picking it up again a little
bit in the fall and you see it's
exactly opposite right so so how do we
reconcile this
well we reconcile it by trying to
understand our growth better
right how much it's growing how much we
have to mow
what height we're mowing at now
currently we're mowing with people
soon sports fields are going to be an
easy adaptation for
a better robotic autonomous mowing when
we see it for sure
there's going to be a future for this
technology i think
especially once they can do the patterns
that we become so accustomed to which
you know i think they're pretty close to
development but since we're talking
about bowling and we're talking about
traffic
let me draw your attention to some old
michigan state research that
tim vinini many years ago did with trey
rogers
out at msu where they were looking at a
different a number of different
fertilizer programs and i don't think
those are necessarily uh relative to
what the point we're trying to make here
this is the number of simulated soccer
games you can get on a field
mowing once per week versus mowing twice
per week
and you can see it's quite a bit of an
improvement if even with a
medium fertilizer program you're going
from
maybe about 14 games that allow you to
keep acceptable turf cover
to about 24 games right that's a pretty
significant
increase and you see that in every case
independent
independent in some ways of the
fertilizer use right
so mowing moore and doug talked about
this yesterday in the golf session
mowing more
actually does stimulate growth so if
you've got some
uh growth going mowing more frequently
is a way
of keeping up with some traffic
tolerance even if it is a
two inch height of cut like this soccer
field was tested now
we're gonna make our transition to what
evan is our resident expert on
but we'll start out with the reality
that probably is not reflected in this
wonderful article we're gonna talk about
that got published in sports field
managed but let me just remind everybody
that there are actual standards
that if you're in the business of
managing baseball fields and baseball is
by far one of the trickiest as we'll
talk about with evan in a second
the ball interacts with two different
surfaces but
particularly the standards on the skin
surfaces
become really important to understand
now there's been some interesting work
done in this area even back into
connecticut
uh bill dest carl gillard have done a
bunch of work there two good solid soil
scientists
have really done good work in this area
years ago where they looked at a variety
of uh different mixes um and
with and without calcine clay looking at
the various
kinds of materials you could use uh in
baseball infields in connecticut
and they found you know significant
impacts of the amount of soil
significant impacts of the amount of
calcium clay but one of the things that
really came out
was that moisture had a big effect on
friction now we're going to start to get
into these words shear and friction
uh in a second as we geek out on this
but evan before i bring you in i want to
tell you we've thought about this before
with chase straw and gerald henry who
have done
obviously surface hardness testing this
is some work that siffers and beards
have looked at
zippers and beard looked at a long time
ago where they were dropping the clegg
hammer on different surfaces you know
fourteen hundred g max values on a
cement floor
and they actually did a couple of
infields uh back in the day they were
doing some research back then also on
on inclusion uh mesh conclusion stuff
uh that actually dan dinelli's starting
to look at uh for
uh golf courses and so they've developed
these ways of testing these fields
chase has done this work with gerald and
then they're coming up
with these really cool um maps
of these surfaces and one of the things
they talk about that i know you do in
the article is consistency
now before i introduce you and i'll talk
a little bit about your work and try to
set you up pretty good
so you can answer some questions is a
little homage to brother brosnan who is
a lot older than he looks
uh and was young when he worked with
mcnitt uh and had a little stint many
people might not know
out at the university hawaii unless you
think jim wasn't the surfing type
jim had developed that you know whatever
the pen thing is you call it evan that
shoots the
missile baseballs uh into the ground
that was
a step above the jugs gun that probably
everybody else was
you know the pitching machine that
everybody else was using
and that all that of course did this
wonderful article that just got
published uh
at least i just saw it recently and back
last month so sorry i didn't pick up on
it right away evan
but it looks like you took about you
took data from
40 000 batted balls during the 2020 uh
baseball season and uh sort of looked at
how
uh much like the other guys were doing
with the variability
uh in the field uh in the sports field
you did it to the baseball infields now
you in this article and i'm going to
commend this article to anybody that
gets involved in this you talked about
consistency
uh bounce pace spin cork board stuff
the cleating in and out you got all this
cool data
you know you did it all this is you know
carl and i are fascinated about this in
golf
as well and that's part of the reason
you're here so
i wanted to give you a chance now to
first say uh thanks for doing this
uh great work and then you know
obviously a lot of people we deal with
in
uh you know in my extension life and you
know with your keystone sports field
guys the cape mogu guys
you know not everybody's got resources
uh not everybody has the same kind of
surfaces not p
people can't cover their infields right
not everybody's got a major league
or a minor league operation so i want to
give you a chance to talk about your
wealth of experience in this area evan
and where somebody might start and
because you said consistency
is important what are some of the
consistency factors
that you you think are important so
sorry for
uh being so long-winded uh but
but i really wanted to give everybody a
chance who's not familiar with this kind
of stuff
to understand it a little bit better so
welcome to the show
where would you tell people to start
with this evan in the
real world that isn't like the ballpark
behind
sure well thanks so much for having me
on i'm a great admirer of all the
content you guys put out and uh it's
great to join um i think
you know the biggest thing with
consistency is that the the ball has to
react the way the player sort of expects
it to
and so when you if you're a shortstop or
a third baseman or
whatever you're playing um as soon as
that ball is hit you make a subconscious
calculation about where the ball is
going to end up
and you do that based on your experience
of how the ball normally reacts and so
you're going to take that first step to
take the right angle based on what you
predict so that's kind of the first
thing and that part it's really not so
different from even hitting a fastball
where you have to kind of predict
where the ball is going to be without
really being able to to watch it hit the
bat so to speak in real time
so um you know pro athletes are so
they're so good that no matter how fast
the ball is traveling they can pretty
much feel that as long as they
can anticipate what's going to happen so
as long as it's consistent i think the
speed
and the balance those things are kind of
secondary
but when it comes back to maybe at a
lower level that might not be the case
and so you really are depending on um
the ball reacting exactly the same way
all the time right now when it comes
let me lead you up a little bit because
now at the lower levels you've got two
possibilities maybe this is a way to
bifurcate the conversation
do you would you recommend guys mostly
had grass right because there's no rules
or would you recommend they had all
skinned infield if they had their drugs
and then of course i showed the picture
of the synthetic turf
which enters in and i've been a strong
advocate for the further north you get
is synthetic turf on baseball fields is
if consistency is what you're after man
that is a way to get it i think first
let's start with what do you like to see
mostly dirt or grass and dirt or does
that make it hard
yeah i think you can go both ways i mean
on a full-size infield at least
maintaining the the crown and the grade
over time is going to be a little more
difficult because that water can erode
the soil a little bit more easily
obviously in that kind of a scenario
you're not putting a tarp on when it's
raining
the flip side is that there's no lips
there's no lips to
maintain and you know at the youth level
if you don't obviously if you don't have
access to water you're not you're not
being able to soak the infield down you
definitely don't have the same resources
to take care of your lips
and i'll tell you you know that in
certainly in the major leagues or in the
minor leagues
good good edges are what separate you
know
average fields from good fields and you
can it's hard to know unless you're out
there walking around and feeling what
it's like
so i i totally understand um not having
that extra
extra maintenance headache of
maintaining the lips sucking dirt out of
there with with vacuum cleaners and
hosing it out every two weeks and it's a
lot of work to maintain those edges the
right way and so i think definitely
there is a place for the all skin
surface how long until um
we think we're at a place where uh when
you were with the pirates and i you know
i'm pals with dan cunningham
dan as i has taught me a lot in the 30
years we've been absolutely
acting about you know the nuances of
taking care of these things and he's
like yeah frank
anybody can strike the grass let me tell
you how hard the infield is and
they certainly can subtly feel like they
adjust things let's start with a bit of
a myth you dispel
in the article i remember when derek
jeter got a little bit older the thought
was well
you know the message from upstairs was
well can't you raise the height on the
grass and
won't that slow the ball down let's
start there how does the height of the
grass and the way we deal with the turf
surfaces
impact the consistency stuff we're
talking about
yeah i think definitely in an extreme
case it can play a big role i mean if
you're mowing up four inches and you hit
a
you know ball into that it's gonna just
the same way that when um
you know at the u.s open when the rough
is cut at six inches or whatever it is
it's that's going to definitely affect
the way the club interacts with the ball
whatever
but you know at a more micro scale i
think the difference between
uh cutting at an inch and an eighth and
an inch and a sixteenth it's hard to
imagine that that plays a pretty big
difference the
sometimes for like as you mentioned in
an article perception's reality though
and i've never done this i've never done
this personally but i've heard stories
of like a team going out of town the
manager
you know saying hey we really want to
speed the infield up and let's the team
plays really good while they're out of
town and when they come back you just
tell them that yeah you cut it down by
an eighth of an inch
they're not going to go out there with a
prism gauge and check you know what your
height of god is
does rolling have a place in keeping
these fields be they gran
infield's grass or infield uh consistent
do you see
rolling as part of what even a smaller
operation could do to bring some
consistency if you can't do all the
things that
maybe you know you'd like to do i do
think rolling has a place um
for keeping the surface smooth
definitely i i know certainly in
this time of year it's really important
to get a good good roll to repack your
infield
after the freeze thaw um cycles over the
winter i heard brian winka i think talk
about that recently on this show
and um but definitely even on the
infield grass for
from a consistency and smoothness
standpoint that can be a good idea
obviously you don't want to overdo it
and induce compaction and you know cause
yourself more headaches but i think that
that can be a good tool
okay so again part of what makes it
um for you guys to dial in is the
material that you use
uh we talked about this with wink the
last time i i'm like a
dog with a bone about it because
honestly i feel that this is probably
where kids are in fact
at the greatest risk relative to field
safety because a projectile hello
is coming to them and i think as you
were brosnan said about
40 to 60 percent is reduced right so
now we know ball velocity because we got
all that data
and you're telling me it's 40 to 60
percent that means a kid could hit it at
somebody at 40 miles an hour 50 miles an
hour
pretty easily if it's a big kid in a
youth league
um how much uh are we
worried about that when we roll and then
the issue with regard to materials in
the dirt you know in the dirt skin
that the ball's hitting yeah i'm glad to
hear you use the d word as an academic
because sometimes when i say the word
dirt
around the circles of people that i hang
with you know they look at you like you
kick their dog or something
but um i think
i think from the standpoint of
predictable hops
um that cleat and clean out concept is
really important and so having the right
material will help
help with that and certainly just
grooming getting out there with a nail
drag
even if it's not every day every few
days when you have the right moisture
and if if you're in a scenario where you
don't have access to water
it's really important to take advantage
after a rainfall to get out there when
the surface is firm but that you can
actually get the nails to penetrate into
the surface
so you can scarify those cleat marks out
and that's something that at a high
level it's done
every day or potentially multiple times
a day but at the youth level you know
you don't really have the
the resources to be able to do that but
try try and time it right and take
advantage after that rains
that rainfall that you can actually um
smooth the surface out with a nail drag
and then possibly get a roll on it to
recompact everything
okay the big dilemma as as i've come to
understand
uh geeking out on infield stuff uh is
uh management of moisture and the
strength we're sharing that about
um you know sneaking in sneaking in
during
during
the rain uh dan laments and i'm sure the
old the
person at wrigley that plays day games
laments when
they get a perfect uh when they start a
day game and then the et comes and the
moisture starts to come out of it
right and uh your point about
it being consistent and wanted to be the
same way dan used to want to go out in
the middle of the fifth inning and wet
the field down again and then
no no no more that and so
how do you deal with that shifting
moisture that occurs
you know obviously it happens in a
professional game but these are
kids now that may play spring sports on
a couple of days after a
they come back it's been dry for five
days they don't have the ability to
water now they're playing on a totally
different field
what would you tell a guy managing a
field like that how to keep those kids
safe
and try to do the best you can to keep
that field consistent under that known
variability that's gonna happen yeah man
i wish i had a better answer
um that's that's a tough one when you
when you can't when you can't add any
water it's
very difficult um i think one thing that
can help to some degree is making sure
you do have a layer of conditioner on
the field
the conditioner is talked about a lot in
terms of managing the moisture holding
moisture and whatnot and
that's not really what i'm getting at
it's more to do with
filling in small imperfections in the
surface so one thing that will happen is
this
as it gets harder obviously this surface
is going to be more rigid and so if you
do have one of those pock marks and the
ball hits it
it's more likely to carry them as
opposed to um when the
the soil does have some moisture in it
this the surface is really going to
deform again around the ball and that's
one of the things i kind of talk about
in that article
so i think although the conditioner is
not it's not a total it's not a perfect
solution it's not a substitute for nail
dragon having a smooth
you know underlying surface it can help
a little bit because those particles
will
fill in some of the small depressions
and can help kind of insulate
or shield the surface so to speak from
that ball hitting it and so that can
help reduce some bad hops too just
having that
material on top and it also lets the
players even fix little depressions on
their own with their cleats during the
game they can kind of fill them in as
they go so i mean that that's what i'm
thinking about i got i got
one more sort of technical question and
one more sort of baseball question about
how this fits into the nutball analytics
that
that is modern baseball these days but
when you have a sense that maybe
the field's going to have that
variability and you're trying to work
with your athletes about it
would you recommend occasionally to
raise the height
to slow the ball down or i mean are we
getting closer to the point where
sports guys even at school districts are
going to have ways to
measure the performance of these fields
like we're doing on grass fields these
infield systems now and then be able to
tell the coach you know it's going to be
a fast hard field today or
it's going to be a slow left field like
we do in golf right i mean the masters
was hard and fast and then we're going
to get some rain and it's going to be
you know a little bit softer do you
think we're going to be able to get to
that place or do
did you come back for your phd to help
us get to that place where we can start
to use these numbers to make decisions
yeah i think it's a black box i mean
there's really no way to measure a lot
of the things that we talk about and
even one of the things that i talk about
in that article
i don't have ways to measure most of
them you know on a baseball field um
some of the synthetic turf companies
have done some work with high speed
imaging actually to measure the angle
the ball is coming off at and those kind
of things and there's a ton of research
on cricket
and tennis which are pretty analogous
but baseball it is a little different
because like you said at the top
you have the two different surfaces to
deal with and
i think good circling back to this
question you know on the
on the grass as far as like raising the
height up or lowering the height down a
lot of times
the turf area is going to it's almost
always going to be slower it's going to
play slower than
the skin area so if you really want the
two to be equal it's almost like
anything you can do to speed the grass
up or slow the
dirt down to make it more equal is going
to be sort of in your benefit and that's
not that's not always true but i think
in general that's the case
i think the key here to me based on the
yard work what you're showing is that
moisture if you have baseball fields
that have skinned infields
and grass you have to have water
available
you simply now dan would say you need a
cover too
that's a different animal is that as
important than
having the ability to put water
particularly in the northeast or
is a cover uh or both
well i think they kind of go hand in
hand because if you have enough labor
it's really comes down to the labor
right if you have enough people to be
able to put the tarp on
you might you definitely have enough to
be able to soak it down also
there's there's other ways around that
you can install like like another set of
skin heads that will
water some parts of the dirt but you're
still going to have to touch it up by
hand
because there's no irrigation system
that can handle that geometry really
that well
i guess one last point on the
consistency part of the of the turf is
one thing that happens to lower level
baseball fields a lot
in the grass area is as the turf wears
it gets really clumpy
and those those can cause like bad
bounces too especially if you're dealing
with a bunch type
grass like a perennial rye um the blue
grass
you know has obviously different traits
in general but it does
it wears a little bit more evenly it
doesn't tend to form those clumps quite
as bad and so that can help keep it a
little bit smoother too
so how long until uh sabermetrics starts
to integrate
data from the baseball fields
performance
characteristics that you're now learning
how to
characterize yeah it would be cool um i
it's funny to talk to like the baseball
people they seem to not be that
interested in it like so when i was at
the
when i was at the at the pirates i made
friends with a couple of the analytics
people and i asked one of them like hey
do you have any data you know on the way
the ball bounces and stuff and
he kind of looked at me and he's like oh
like i mean i've never really thought
about that before
like we're really more interested in the
balls going up and the ball is going
down
that's what they're looking at like the
launch angles and yeah if it if it's hit
on the ground that's kind of like a lost
cause to them in a lot of cases
yeah and and and if you're a yankee
infielder it doesn't matter
if you don't want the ball on the ground
because they can't freaking catch it if
they catch it they're lucky to get at
the first base
don't get me screwed you got my home
they're having a tough time
early in the year defense is simply not
valued uh and that's probably why they
don't care about these things yeah
i see a comment here from ben palmer
about watering skins being difficult
with small stuff
it's totally a great comment ben i
totally agree um it's just not practical
in those kind of cases
having the right material does it does
go a long way to
not just to withstand rain events but to
hold
on to that moisture and keep it playable
for a longer period of time after you do
get some
and it definitely goes without saying
that but i'll just say it to be clear
the water content is everything on the
infield skin if you're after this cleat
and clean out and
and the optimum ball response and if you
can't water at all there's just no way
to really achieve that so
you can still take steps to make it as
good as as good as you can
if i have the right material we got a
question carl
yeah so uh actually vitas has had a
question um
talking about if you're kind of a
minimal maintenance field that you frank
you showed a picture earlier of
what i would call a minimum maintenance
field what is sort of that the first
thing you would
uh tell them to go after the first kind
of uh
resource maybe they're able to convince
maybe this is a school district hey i
need to put some
some infrastructure on this field some
more money what's the first thing you
would tell them is it a
soil moisture thing is it a you know a
soil texture amendment what would be the
first thing you'd go after
so i think the thing that we talk about
often in sports surf is managing the
field within the field and i know frank
you've talked about that
on overseeding you know just an air fine
doing things down the middle of the
field if you can
and the same concept applies to baseball
and it's even a smaller area so most you
know
we talked about the infield skin here a
lot but um
really the the mound and the home plate
are the absolute most important parts of
the field and
so keeping those in in good condition
will go a long way and
one of the i wouldn't say the easiest
things but we're talking about one of
the first
you know relatively cheap things you can
do is uh installing
like an easy to maintenance easy to
maintain clay not
not the most expensive you know
high-tech major league stiff
black gumbo clay but just you know
you're at your your less plastic
mountain clay and then and then
maintaining it with a tarp so buy it buy
don't buy a landscape tarp at lowe's you
know buy a real
thick vinyl or polyester tarp that's
meant for a baseball field
and keep your areas covered it'll help
keep the water out but it's also going
to help keep the water in
and you'll find that you use less
material that way because it doesn't
displace as badly so
that's a little bit of a learning curve
taking care of the clay you know if you
haven't before
but um the pitchers are going to
appreciate it the batters are going to
appreciate it and that's really that's
sort of the low hanging fruit i think to
get
get started anyway is is installing the
clay and then keeping the moisture right
that is an absolute perfect way to end
this time evan thank you so much for
taking the time what a joy
uh it's opening you know i'm all happy
these days because baseball's back in
in business and we're going to have a
whole long season i hope so
thanks for taking the time al forgive
you for being at penn state because
you're
wisconsin otherwise no i always got
trouble with those penn state guys carl
get us out of here
yeah thanks to everyone for joining
halfway through our cornell turf show
this year
uh the link to evan's article will be
below in the youtube video and it'll be
attached to our podcast as well so
uh thanks everybody for joining we'll be
back next thursday for our golf
uh episode see you all then appreciate
that evan
see you carl this has been a production
of cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu